if the gestures of passing motorists in
London is anything to go by public
support for striking nurses is strong
but the chanting disguises a depression
within the picket lines they say it
isn't just about pay it's about the
desperate state of the NHS
critical Candace be Joy Sebastian says
he fears for the future our experienced
nurses are now leaving for
um private and healthcare companies and
agencies so NHS is losing billions in
recruiting them training them and
retaining them some of my colleagues
left and it just really ashamed that
they had to make that choice but that's
what they have to do to get the food on
the table hit their homes
they're calling out to keep the NHS
alive but it's on its knees and many in
the medical profession believe the
deeper the crisis the stronger the
likelihood is that privatization will be
foisted upon them
some healthcare professionals believe
it's no coincidence that a long run of
underfunding in the NHS runs alongside
the growth of the private sector
currently private hospitals they don't
train any staff they don't support them
they don't educate them they totally
rely on NHS staff to be doing extra
sessions in the Private Hospital
um so the the the the sending of NHS
patients to the private sector actually
undermines the stabilization and the
building back of the NHS and so as the
NHS comes under increasing pressure the
private sector is flourishing but the
NHS is massive by comparison it has a
hundred and fifty thousand beds there
are only nine thousand in the private
sector
routine private surgery though is cost
effective and that helps the NHS when it
pays for private providers to carry out
operations but what's more lucrative for
the private sector is to take on
patients who pay their own way recent
estimates show a 33 increase in this
business over two years that adds to Big
profits from health insurance treatment
that's a new Dynamic and that's actually
more worrying from my perspective it has
several repercussions but it's certainly
the first step towards a two-tier system
we see sort of a separating off of high
quality High Access healthcare for
people who are affluent can afford it
and a subpar service for everyone else
the Striking nurses have taken their
grievances to the government in the hope
of a compromise on pay their patients
need to worry about a different
compromise the dangers of a two-tier
system by default Andrew Simmons Al
Jazeera London